tunisia is facing its biggest political
crisis since the arab spring the
revolution in 2011 toppled president
zainab
he'd been accused of years of rights
abuses and corruption
[Applause]
critics of the current president kais
saeed say his version of a new
constitution threatens to take the
country backwards
we are back to an autocratic rule where
all the powers rest in the hands of the
president
on sunday the head of tunisia's
constitution committee lashed out saying
the president's proposal significantly
changes the committee's work and paves
the way for a return to dictatorship
if we've been following all let's say
the decisions taken by president syed
since his power grab on july 25th last
year it's obvious that the present side
is only
abiding or deciding based on his own
thoughts and his own will and actually
this wasn't quite this wasn't a surprise
the president's draft enhances the
powers of his office while weakening
parliament
he's found support among tunisians
frustrated by years of political
paralysis and desperate for the economy
to improve
but to his critics it is a power grab
that if adopted will erode tunisia's
fledgling democracy the only country to
make meaningful political gains during
the arab spring
a referendum on the proposal is
scheduled for july 25th zane vasravi al
jazeera